when I make promises I keep them I am
announcing today that the United States
will withdraw from the Iran nuclear deal
the fact is this was a horrible
one-sided deal that should have never
ever been made it didn't bring calm it
didn't bring peace and it never will
in the meantime powerful sanctions will
go into full effect if the regime
continues its nuclear aspirations it
will have bigger problems than it has
ever had before
president Trump pulling the u.s. out of
the Iran nuclear deal swift reaction
European allies releasing a statement
together it is with regret and concern
that we the leaders of France Germany
and nighted Kingdom take note of
President Trump's decision to withdraw
the United States of America from the
jcpoa together we emphasize our
continuing commitment to that agreement
this agreement remains important for our
shared security we urged the u.s. to
ensure that the structures of the jcpoa
can remain intact
and to avoid taking action which
obstructs its full implementation by all
other parties to the deal saying
essentially they're negotiating further
not all countries sharing that Saudi
Arabia tweeting out the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia fully supports the measures taken
by @potus president nighted States with
regards to the jcpoa
we always had reservations with regards
to sunset clauses ballistic missiles
program and Iran's support for terrorism
and the region similar statements coming
from the UAE Bahrain the Gulf allies and
of course Israel let's bring in our
panel mats slap contributor with the
hill maybe Stoddard associated there a
real clear politics and host of No
Labels radio on Sirius XM an Eli Lake
columnist for Bloomberg view Eli looking
at across the board the world reaction
your take on this and the hopes that
perhaps you heard the Secretary of
Treasury say there may be a
renegotiation in the offing well I mean
there's also this period of 90 and 180
days for the Rhian of the sanctions
there are now negotiations that I guess
have been announced between Iran and the
European allies
and so far there has not been any kind
of clear statement from the Iranians as
to saying that they're going to begin
you know enriching beyond the limits on
uranium or building up their program you
know kind of or kicking out inspectors
all of that is pretty good and I think
in some ways it could be a continuation
of the strategy that Trump has pursued
really since the beginning of his
presidency which is to try to
renegotiate a better deal but there is a
paradox also in what he said today
which is that he really made a very
clear statement of solidarity with the
Iranian people and the question is you
know if Trump negotiates a bargain with
the Iranian regime where does that leave
the Iranian people I think now is a
perfect opportunity for Trump to begin
thinking about ways to sort of support
the democracy movement which has been
gaining momentum really since late
December in Iran right exactly those
protests in December and January
essentially a weakening economy in Iran
here is the president of Iran reacting
to this announcement after President
Trump spoke in shop
ma sha tonight we witnessed an important
historic experience the same thing that
we have said and repeated for 40 years
has now happened so honey Iran is a
country that is loyal to its commitments
and the u.s. is a country that never
sticks to its commitments Matt your
thought on that and you hear it not only
obviously from the Iranians but other
opponents of this action saying if the
US can't keep its international deals
how does any country believe that the
u.s. can keep keep agreements right of
course there's no future between an
American bilateral relationship with the
mullahs in Iran we have to look past the
mullahs in Iran to the future and I
agree with Eli completely it's about the
Iranian people who in many ways are
lined like like no other country in the
region to actually be in a position
where they could be allied with us on
several key issues so it's about looking
past the mullahs it's about weakening
the mullahs unfortunately we'll never
get the billions of dollars back to back
down at the beginning of this
arrangement with President Obama but
this does knock the second big pillar
out of the Obama legacy the Iran nuclear
agreement is dead
now it can be renegotiated there are
there are ways in which it transitions
but the fundamental premise of it is
dead and I have to say one other thing
when you have John Bolton and Secretary
of State Mark Pompeo in their staffing
the president to fulfill his promises
great things can happen maybe you know
you hear some Democrats out there saying
this was the wrong move because there's
nothing the next step is not set in
stone yet we don't know the way forward
and they're comparing it to Obamacare
and repeal on the replace where there
wasn't that next step but here are some
Democrats about this deal as it came to
pass we should not go forward with this
agreement the whole purpose of our
negotiation was to ensure that there
would be no pathway for Iran to achieve
nuclear weapons capability and this deal
doesn't achieve that I've said more
times than I can count that I posed a
deal and it was announced I voted
against here on the House floor
obviously it be they're all saying
different things now what about this
move to death well Brett this was a
flawed agreement from day one and there
were critics on both sides that's that's
perfectly clear right now there are
senior members on Capitol Hill House
Armed Services Committee Chairman a
Republican senior members of the foreign
I mean sorry of the Foreign Affairs
Committee senior members of the House
Armed Services Committee who are
Republicans very worried about the fact
that you get out of this deal and you're
left in a perilous place very difficult
it makes the challenge with North Korea
much more difficult and it creates a
whole host of problems and consequences
in the years to come it might have
allowed for time for the kind of sort of
democracy building and fighting for
freedom that Eli Lake wrote so
eloquently about today it might have
helped us keep our word with our allies
area where we're really struggling
because that we actually don't have a
new NAFTA deal president microrna France
said getting out of this would be insane
because there's really nothing left in
its place I think that these next
critical days and weeks are going to
tell us whether or not he can actually
keep Iran at the table and whether our
European allies can keep them from some
kind of proliferation activity and
keep them at the table and if President
Trump can end up renegotiating something
that will be a masterstroke as of now
we're just gonna have to wait and see
what they're willing to give well part
of this speech was to say here's your
opportunity Iran right this deal was not
working you could still negotiate it but
Eli very quickly the same time you have
Secretary of State Pompeo on the ground
in North Korea who knows he could come
home with three Americans as part of a
laying the groundwork for this what is
supposed to be a locked-in meeting now
put the juxtaposition of those two
things well I actually think that what
Trump did today could help in North
Korea because it shows that he's willing
to defy you know establishment foreign
policy Washington and impose crippling
sanctions over the objection that was
closest to allies and everything else
you know I argued in columns that you
know he should wait it out and in some
ways if the North Koreans are looking at
that I think that they might say to
themselves you know we don't necessarily
want to cross this guy we're in the good
graces now imagine what happens if these
negotiations don't work out it could be
perilous for us that's just I mean
that's one calculus I think it's really
hard to predict what Kim jong-un will do
he's I don't think any intelligence
agency really can get inside of his head
but I do think that there could be this
benefit of it which is that you know
Trump is a disrupter and he is willing
to do things which other adversaries did
not think was possible and that could be
a benefit in the context of North Korean
negotiations it's a hundred percent true
panel thank you